Cuando estaba embarazada me frustré mucho.
No comas fiambres, haz esta prueba prenatal en particular.
¿Por qué esa decisión? ¿Por qué no hiciste otra cosa?
Sentía que me pedían que hiciera cosas, y nunca me decían por qué.
[Nuestra forma de trabajar]
A veces en el mundo de la crianza moderna parece que no puedes triunfar.
Si vuelvo a trabajar, paso menos tiempo con mis hijos.
¿Y si no reciben la atención necesaria para desarrollarse adecuadamente?
Si me quedo en casa y renuncio a mi flujo de ingresos,
¿lamentaré mi decisión?
Hay muchos consejos contradictorios dando vueltas
sobre si quedarse en casa o volver al trabajo,
y tratar de elegir entre las dos cosas puede ser algo confuso y emocional.
Amas a tus hijos y quieres lo mejor para ellos,
pero ¿qué significa lo mejor cuando todos tienen una opinión diferente?
Hay muchas variaciones de padres que puede haber en un hogar,
y creo que más familias deberían estar preguntándose
si tiene sentido que el hombre se quede en la casa.
Pero la verdad es que hoy en día,
las discusiones sobre los padres que se quedan en casa
se centran en las mujeres en particular.
Y por lo general las mujeres dicen que sienten
que lo que hacen durante el día va a determinar a un nivel profundo
qué clase de madre y persona son.
Eso es un gran peso ponerse como padre.
Y si te sientes observada
al decirle a alguien que vuelves al trabajo o que no,
eso puede socavar tu confianza.
Decidí indagar y descubrirlo.
¿Es mejor quedarse en casa o volver a trabajar?
Es una decisión emocional, sí,
pero como economista he aprendido que podemos usar los datos
como ayuda para transitar esas decisiones difíciles
y sentirnos cómodos de tomar la mejor decisión para la familia.
Hay tres factores principales a considerar antes de decidir.
Primero, debes pensar
cómo afectará esta decisión el presupuesto familiar.
Hagamos algunas cuentas.
Digamos que el ingreso en el hogar es de USD 100 000,
cada uno aporta USD 50 000.
Es decir, quedan unos USD 85 000 libres de impuestos.
Si ambos trabajan
y la familia paga USD 1500 al mes para el cuidado de los niños,
el ingreso total disponible sería de USD 67 000 al año.
¿Me sigues?
Si decides quedarte en casa,
la familia recibe menos dinero pero no paga por el cuidado de los niños.
El ingreso disponible se reduce en este escenario,
pero no tanto como sin incluir el factor del cuidado de los niños.
Es más complicado si el cuidado de los niños es más costoso en tu zona.
Una niñera puede costar USD 40 o 50 000 al año
depende de dónde vivas.
Si ese es el caso en tu vecindario, en el escenario que describí,
acabaría por completo con el ingreso de uno de los padres,
y estarían mejor financieramente si uno de los padres se queda en casa.
Por supuesto, esto es solo un análisis a corto plazo.
El cuidado infantil es menos costoso a veces con los niños en la escuela,
y puedes tener un ingreso mayor más tarde así que ten eso en cuenta, si puedes.
Una vez echadas las cuentas, sabrás lo que es posible
y podrás tomar una decisión con más información,
lo cual debería darte más poder.
Segundo, hablemos sobre lo que es mejor para los hijos.
Podrías pensar que esto debería ser el núcleo de tu decisión,
pero en realidad no hay una respuesta correcta.
Según estudios de Europa y EE.UU.,
la decisión de volver a trabajar o quedarse en casa
no creará ni destruirá el éxito futuro de los hijos.
La investigación muestra que dos padres que trabajan a tiempo completo
tiene un efecto similar en las notas futuras de los hijos y en el ingreso
que si un padre trabaja y el otro no.
Lo que parece ser más importante es el entorno
en el que los hijos pasarán su tiempo libre.
Lo importante es que participen en actividades enriquecedoras;
leer, practicar sus habilidades motoras, interactuar con otros niños,
van a prosperar ya sea que estés o no en casa con ellos.
Hay un matiz en los datos.
Por ejemplo, los estudios han encontrado
que si ambos padres trabajan,
los niños de familias pobres son impactados positivamente,
y los niños de familias más ricas de manera menos positiva.
Entonces dependiendo de la configuración tu hogar,
los efectos en los hijos podrían ser un poco positivos
o un poco negativos,
pero el impacto general es insignificante.
Ahora quiero marcar una excepción: la licencia por maternidad.
Hay un creciente cuerpo de evidencia que sugiere que a los bebés les va mejor
si sus madres se toman licencia por maternidad.
Los primeros días con tu hijo pueden afectar su desarrollo,
así que si tienes una licencia paga, deberías tomarla,
y si no, tal vez considerar
tomar una licencia no remunerada durante esos primeros meses,
si tu presupuesto lo permite.
Y finalmente, pregúntate, ¿qué quiero?
Si bien esto puede parecer simple,
es el factor que parece ser el mayor tabú a explorar.
Al hablar con padres, encuentro que si una mujer elige quedarse en casa,
a menudo se siente obligada a decir
que tomó esta decisión para el desarrollo óptimo de sus hijos.
Lo cual, claro, puede ser parte de la razón,
pero es perfectamente aceptable decir "Este es el estilo de vida que prefiero"
o "esto funciona para mi familia".
Lo mismo vale para la madre trabajadora.
Decir: "Me gusta mi empleo, y por eso regresé al trabajo", es suficiente.
Si quieres volver a trabajar, eso es genial.
Tienes suerte de tener un empleo que amas
y tienes el derecho de conservarlo una vez que te conviertes en madre.
Sé honesta contigo misma sobre lo que te gustaría hacer.
Si eres sincera al respecto, te garantizas sentirte más feliz,
lo que te permitirá ser la mejor versión de madre que puedes ser,
y ¿no es esa la idea?
No hay bien ni mal cuando se trata de ser padres.
La mejor decisión
es la que hará, a tu familia y a ti, los más felices.
Depende de ti decidir qué sigue.
Al reconocer que la decisión de quedarse en casa o no
es solo eso, una decisión,
con factores que te empujan en varias direcciones,
podemos evitar la culpa y disfrutar de lo mejor para nuestras familias.